Україна та Росія "поважають територіальну цілісність одна одної
і підтверджують непорушність існуючих між ними кордонів" -
це прописано у все ще чинному Договорі про дружбу, співробітництво
та партнерство між Україною та Росією.
Анексувавши Крим і розпочавши агресію на Донбасі у 2014 році,
Москва зухвало порушила всі ці зобов'язання.
І от чотири роки потому президент Порошенко анонсував розірвання договору.
Дія договору, що набув чинності в квітні 1999-го, автоматично подовжується кожні 10 років,
і чергове десятиліття його чинності спливає у квітні 2019 року.
Про бажання зупинити дію договору необхідно повідомити за шість місяців до закінчення декади,
тобто до 1 жовтня 2018-го.
Тож, очікується, що МЗС України вже найближчим часом
надасть необхідний пакет документів для припинення договору.
Противники розриву договору твердять, що в інтересах Києва,
щоб Москва понесла відповідальність за порушення цього договору.
Якщо ж його скасують - зникне діючий юридичний документ,
на який Україна могла б посилатися у міжнародних судових позовах проти Росії.
Тому радять не розривати договір, а привести його до реалій сьогодення,
з урахуванням думки експертів у галузі міжнародного права.
Серед аргументів за розрив документа називають сам факт
грубого порушення Росією кордонів України,
що де-факто денонсувало дію договору.
Тому саме Москва несе відповідальність за порушення норм міжнародного права.
Правники запевняють: розірваний договір не є підставою
не розглядати порушення його положень в минулому.
Навпаки, допоки договір чинний, міжнародні судові інстанції
не розглядатимуть позов про його порушення,
поки на це не дасть згоду російська влада.
Тобто ініціювати розгляд такого позову українській стороні буде легше після розірвання договору.